okay center period and amplitude now
have a look at this remember what we did
to get this x naught right what is
x naught x naught is how far i went up
right
so i used to have you know a sine curve
like this
okay and i've gone up x naught units now
if i shift the whole thing
this center of motion is at x equals
zero right
so my new center of motion is going to
be
x naught units above right so 0
all the way up to x naught okay so
therefore
uh the center of motion i can just read
it off
this equation up here okay the center of
motion is x naught which is three and a
half
in this case all you need to say right
period
over here period is determined by the
coefficient of
t right that's going to tell you how
many times it repeats in a given
space and time so that's m right that's
the n and after so where's the end here
it's there and that's actually the
reason why i wrote it so it's more
obvious to me
the period is going to be two pi on m
right just two pi on one
so there's the q now
amplitude
amplitude amplitude is a okay that
number up there
having a look at this equation right and
this equation
a doesn't correspond to anything at
least not directly right so i can't read
off amplitude in the same way that i
read off center
and period so what could i do to work
out amplitude
any suggestions
okay can we go for t equals zero right
what would that be able to tell us
now um what what do i know about this
question number one i've got velocity in
terms of where i am
right and i've through that i've worked
out acceleration
also in terms of where i am okay but
unfortunately like i sort of i was a bit
i was a bit bare i was a bit scarce i
haven't told you anything about where it
starts
where it goes after a certain period of
time so getting some initial conditions
will usually be quite useful for this
okay it'll allow us to work out some
constants
but in this case i'm kind of stuck right
so remember all i've got is velocity
and acceleration so i want you to think
about
what is amplitude that was the
definition of amplitude
how would you define amplitude we know
what these two are how would you explain
amplitude to someone who's never heard
the word before
yeah good amplitude has to do with how
far you move up and down
namely this distance right our amplitude
is
is half that distance okay so it's a bit
like diameter versus radius okay
now i can actually work out this
distance because
as i said it's about extremities in
other words it's about position
okay so position in this particular
example is something i know about
right now at those extremities
i should know something about the
velocity right how
fast is the particle object moving at
those extreme points
zero it's not going anywhere those are
those are stationary points
right so therefore here's what i'm going
to write down okay
amplitude can be determined uh you don't
actually have to write this in your
solution but i'm writing it so that you
know why i'm
going to write the equation so that i do
amplitude can be determined
by finding the extremities
okay you find the extremities that'll
turn the amplitude right you can either
find one extremity and just compare it
to the center of motion because i
already know what that is
or find both extremities and then divide
that distance by two
okay the extremities are
where the velocity is zero
okay so i'm going to come back to
all right it's time sorry
i'm going to come back to this first
equation well only equation
that we've been given this one okay this
velocity
should be zero if i put in zero there
i'll get the extremities
okay so zero equals this
okay now right away you ought to notice
okay this is good i'm expecting two
solutions here because it's a quadratic
that's helpful because we ought to find
two extractors right
okay take a minus sign out to make it
just a little easier to factorize
how do i factorize what are the two
numbers i'm after
they add to minus seven multiply twelve
yeah negative three negative four right
okay so therefore my extremities are at
three
and four okay now just pause for a
second does that make sense
because we already know the center of
motion we should be expecting the center
of motion to be right in between these
two
okay check you always need to do when
you work out a number
see if you can correlate that with
things you already know to make sure
that things actually make sense
okay all right so what's my amplitude
um because i know i go between three and
four my center of motion is three and a
half
amplitudes from the center up to either
of those extremities
so there's my amplitude okay happy with
that
all right now last one that was my um
three important piece of information
where at what positions do i reach half
the maximum speed
better i need a few pieces of
information here right firstly it's
going to be an equation to do with x
right okay that's good because all them
have to do so far
but in order to work at half max speed
i've got to work out what the
full max speed is right so how do i do
that
good the the fastest that the particle
can move
is right here or right there right
namely when i pass through that center
of motion okay
so i'm going to take that x equals three
and a half
where do i put it in i put in here
right x equals three and a half sub it
in now before you do anything right
you can sub it into here you'll get the
answer okay
but i think it's probably better to put
it into here
you see why i mean it doesn't matter
that much right but
this has already been um this equation
we've simplified it
so that we get our two extremities right
so three and a half
minus three is a half three and a half
minus four
is negative a half okay so you can
actually already read off
this is part c right the maximum speed
um yeah
is going to come from this equation
right this is v squared don't forget
so v squared will equal up
yeah does that make sense because i just
want v i change this with speed okay
which is the absolute value
so that's the speed i'm after
so if i want to work out what half the
maximum speed is
just divide by 2. now where am i going
to stick that
back into here right and then i'm going
to get some x values out
okay so i'm going to solve
1 on 16. because that's b squared
this equation right sorry this equation
is equal to minus x squared plus
7x minus 12.
okay i can tell you right now you end up
with it's actually they're they're
terrible numbers
sorry i didn't make up the question but
um you're gonna use here you're gonna
have to go to quadratic formula okay and
you're gonna get
x equals now i worked it out
um something plus or minus two other
things
right because you're going to expect it
to happen sort of
around here right so therefore
the plus or minus what's before it ought
to be your center of motion
does that make sense so you get it on
either side of that and i think this is
um
root three on it's a four five four
that's four
there you go so you can verify go this
multiply 3 by 16
use quadratic equation and just verify
that you get that result
and that's it so
just don't forget that shifting the
center of motion will give you a
different
differential equation not very different
just a little bit
but you can use that when you're proving
that something is moving in simple
harmonic motion
that's all there is to it okay